comment est-ce qu'un magistrat des
experts psychiatres ont pu estimer en
toute bonne foi je remet pas du tout en
cause leur bonne foi qu'un individu dans
le déséquilibre psychologique avait déjà
été attestée par un délit aussi grave
que l' incendie de la cathédrale de
nantes comment est ce qu'on n'a pas fait
jouer le principe de précaution en se
disant aussi longtemps que l'intéressé
n'aura pas été jugé sa place est en
prison
[Musique]
fait que cet étranger a été si j'ai bien
compris des bouteilles de son statut de
réfugié a fait l'objet de la part de
l'autorité préfectorale de deux occulter
f2 obligation de quitter le territoire
français successives et qu'elles n'ont
pas été mises à exécution par ce
qu'elles ont été annulés par le juge
administratif par le tribunal
administratif de nantes pour les
français c'est parfaitement
incompréhensible si l'innocuité f il est
logique que l'intéressée quitte le
territoire national il se trouve que
notre procédure n'est pas organisé de
cette façon là la décision de refuser le
statut de réfugié n'entraîne pas
automatiquement le départ d'intéresser
du territoire national je parle même pas
du départ matériel je parle de la
décision juridique de le faire quitter
le territoire national on sait que
malheureusement la réalité est juste
inverse c'est à dire que la cour des
comptes a établi dès 2015 que
95% des déboutés ne quittez pas le
territoire français lorsque la cour
nationale du droit d'asile rejette
définitivement une demande d'asile il
faudrait que ça se traduise
automatiquement par l'obligation faite à
l'intéressé de quitter le territoire
sans que l'intéressé la possibilité de
présenter un nouveau recours parce que
sinon c'est sans fin
là on débouche sur deux autres
difficultés la première c'est la lenteur
de notre procédure judiciaire on
comprend pas très bien pourquoi plus
d'un an après les faits l'intéressé
n'est pas passé en jugement en france
pour cent mille habitants vous avez à
peu près onze juges en allemagne pays
dont le degré de développement
économique est comparable au nôtre
notamment en terme de pib c'est
quasiment 25 juge pour 100000 habitants
ce qui se vérifie au niveau du processus
judiciaire se retrouvent ensuite au
niveau de l'incarcération nous avons en
france à peu près 60 mille places de
prison au royaume uni il y en a 90 7000
pour deux pays qui ont grosso modo la
même population ça se traduit évidemment
par une surpopulation carcérale en
france qui conduit sans doute un certain
nombre de juges des libertés et de la
détention a estimé qu'il est préférable
de ne pas maintenir en incarcération des
personnes dans la situation pénale
pourtant le justifierait le principe de
précaution il est très à la mode par
exemple sur les questions
environnementales
mais il faudrait peut-être qu'ils soient
davantage à la mone sur les questions
qui intéressent directement la sécurité
physique de nos concitoyens comment
est-ce qu'un magistrat des experts
psychiatres ont pu estimer en toute
bonne foi et je remet pas du tout en
cause leur bonne foi qu'un individu dans
le déséquilibre psychologique avait déjà
été attestée par un délit aussi graves
que l'incendié de la cathédrale de
nantes le mans est ce qu'on n'a pas fait
jouer le principe de précaution en se
disant aussi longtemps que l'intéressé
n'aura pas été jugé sa place est en
prison
situation a commencé à se dégrader à
partir de 1981 et en l'espace d'une
dizaine d'années notamment avec les lois
sur l'immigration qui ont été votées à
la fin des années 80 lorsque monsieur
joxe est revenu au ministère de
l'intérieur l'expulsion des étrangers
menaçant leur public n'était plus une
priorité les procédures d'expulsion
avait été complexifier à l'extrême sa
pose la question de la suppression de la
double peine par nicolas sarkozy
lorsqu'il est revenu aux affaires
d'abord comme ministre de l'intérieur à
partir de 2002 puis à nouveau en 2005 il
est probable que cette décision a été
une erreur ça fait 20 ou 30 ans que la
part des dépenses publiques qui en
france sont consacrés à ce que
j'appellerais le régalien civile justice
police gendarmerie pour faire court est
inférieure à la moyenne de l'union
européenne lorsque vous faites ce type
de choix budgétaires et lorsque voulait
prolonger dans la durée vous aboutissez
à des résultats qui sont catastrophiques
pour la sécurité de nos concitoyens